[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصها بشراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بشعار التسامح والتعايش كاس العالم قطر
2022 ينطلق معلنا بدء التظاهرات الكرويه
الاكبر في العالم
في ايران احكام عصيه بالاعدام سماء وهبه
ملبده بالمسيرات وفنانه ايرانيه تحدت
النظام بالحجابلت
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
والعربيه تصل الى خط التماس وتتابع من
هناك
لانه على ذكر المنتخبات العربيه المشاركه
في مونديال قطر مشاهدينا اربع منتخبات
عربيه
في كاس العالم ومع افتتاح المونديال اذا
للمزيد من المتابعه حول الاستعدادات لدى
المنتخبات العربيه والجماهير كذلك نتبع
مراسلين اذان من تونس وليد عبد الله من
الرباط
الزبيري مرحبا بكما همم ابدا همم معك همم
وليد في تونس كيف هي استعدادات المنتخب
كذلك والجماهير في تونس لي متابعه همم
مشاركه التونسي في التصفيات المضيئه
مساء الخير صهيب تونس شهيدت اليوم وتابع
تقريبا تبع الجماهير او حتى غير الجماهير
الرياضيه الحدث الابرز رياضيين افتتاح كاس
العالم وايضا تبعثا اللقاء الافتتاح
تقريبا في الحقيقه الجماهير الرياضيه صهيب
في تونس تابعت هذا الحدث وكانت من قبل
تتابع رحله المنتخب الوطني التونسي لكره
القدم منذ تصفيات المؤهله لاغلى الكؤوس في
العالم على المستويات فريق الوطني والترشح
الصعب امام المنتخب المالي بنتيجه هدف
لصفر في باماكو هو صفر لصفر هنا وحتى ان
الجماهير التونسيه ظلت تواكب التحضيرات
والقائم الموسعه ثم القائمه النهائيه واخر
الاستعدادات ل همم اول لقاء ينتظره تونسي
ضد المنتخب ضد الماركي يوم الثلاثاء صهيب
وايضا كانت اجواء معسكر الفريق التونسي
سواء في الدمام في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه او الان في الدوحه في همم قطر
اخر اخبار المنتخب التونسي كانت تصل لحظه
بلحظه وكنا نتابعها على وسائل الاعلام
ومنصات تواصل الاجتماعي حتى في المقاهي
همم تقريبا كل التونسيين اصبحوا من
المحللين الرياضيين ويتحدثون على التشكيله
عن الاصابات عن الاجواء في المعسكر على كل
اخر استعدادات المنتخب الوطني التونسي
تفيد بان الاجواء طيبه خاصه وان القائمه
التي
الناخب الوطني جلال القادري اعتمدت همم
صهيب التوازن بين الجيل المخضرم والذي
شارك في اكثر من كاس عالميه وايضا الشباب
الصاعد سواء من اللاعبين في الدوري
التونسي او من المحترفين خاصه
الاوروبيه وهو ما قد يجعل المنتخب التونسي
يطمح الى المرور الى الدور الثاني صهيب
لاول مره في تاريخه رغم انه اول فريق عربي
افريقي ينتصر في كاس عالم بذكريات
وسبعين في الارجنتين عندما انتصر واكتسح
المكسيك بثلاثه اهداف لهدف ولكن التخوف كل
تخوف لان المجموعه الرابعه مجموعه المنتخب
التونسي تعتبر مجموع قياسيا صعبه على
اعتبار انها تجمع المنتخب الفرنسي حامل
البطوله في النسخه الاخيره نسخه روسيا
وكذلك المنتخب الدنماركي الذي سيلاقيه
المنتخب التونسي همم يوم الثلاثاء القادم
فضلا عن استرا التي تعتبر من اعطى الفراق
في المستوى العالمي ولكن التونسيون
يحاولون ربما تحقيق المفاجاه مدفوعين
بالجماهير الغفير التي ستحضر التي تقدرها
المراقبون بثلاثين الف مشجع تونسي قد
يكونون في الدوحه وربما تحقيق على الاقل
وهو ادنى ما يطمع اليه المنتخب التونسي
تحقيق انتصار الثالث بعد انتصار المكسيك
وايضا على باناما في نسخه روسيا لما لا
تحقيقه انتصار على الاقل وربما المرور الى
الدور الثاني صهيب نعم نعم الزبير في
الرباط اسود الاطلس كذلك يدخلون العرس
الكروي العالمي همم انهو تحضيراتهم همم
كذلك بفوز كبير على جورجيا همم حدثني عن
المنتخب المغربي هذه المشاركه وكذلك
الجماهير المغربيه كيف تتحضر لاول لقاء
هنا في العاصمه الرباط
المغربيه صهيب سنن نفسه بانجاز تاريخي على
الاقل المرور الى الدور الثاني واعاده
انجاز مكسيكو 86 عندما كان اسود الاطلس
اول منتخب عربي وافريقي ينافس الكبار ويمر
الى الدور الثاني المغاربه يرفعون الصوت
في كل المدن المغربيه ان اسود الاطلس
يتوجه عليهم ان يمروا على الاقل الى ربوع
النهائي لان المغرب بحسب الخبراء
الرياضيين يتوفر على افضل منتخب باسماء
ثقيله وثقيله جدا لاول مره يلعبوا المغرب
بهذه الاسماء الوازنه وتجاوز منتخب المغرب
المشاكل الداخليه مع المدرب السابق وحيد
خليل يزيد ومع حضور المدرب المغربي وليد
الرجراجي بعد انجاز تاريخي مع نادي الوداد
البيضاوي
بالتتويج بالكاس الافريقيه على مستوى عصبه
الابطال الان المنتخب المغربي مكتمل
الصفوف وتجاوز اصابه احد اللاعبين بتعويده
بنجم جديد ق من المدارس الانجليزيه من
مدارس البلجيكيه ومن الدوري الانجليزي
الان الجماهير تمني النفس بالذهاب بعيدا
وبواقعيه كره القدم الشارع الرياضي
المغربي يعي ان منتخبي كرواتيا وبلجيكا
هما جدارين صعبين يحتاج منتخب المغرب الى
التركيز والواقعيه والى قدره حكيم زياش
نجم نادي تشيلسي على خلق المفاجاه بقدرته
على اختراق الصفوف وعلى تسجيله من بعيد
اذا الحدود على الارض هي في غير صالح
المنتخب المغربي ولكن من الممكن لوليد
الرجراجي ان يخلق المفاجاه او يفرح الشارع
الرياضي المغربي نعم صحيح هذا عن المنتخب
المغربي ولكن اليوم مع افتتاح المونديال
عادل هل بدات ملامح الحاله حاله المونديال
همم في الشوارع ربما والمقاهي ال-
المغربيه في متابعه اللقاء الاول اليوم
بين قطر والاكوادور
المقاهي المغربيه هي محجوزه بالكامل طيله
مباريات المونديال المغاربه شعب يعشق كره
القدم من كاس العالم من الدوريات
الاوروبيه من الدوري المغربي الاحتراف
لكره القدم هنالك ايضا استعدادات ايضا من
طرف بعض الشركات الكبرى من اجل خلق منصات
في الساحات الكبرى للجماهير هنالك ايضا
استعداد من طرف الجماهير المغربيه المتجهه
الى قطر عبر جسر جوي لمتابعه اسود الاطلس
في المباريات الثلاثه الاولى هنالك ايضا
هب من مغاربه العالم من اوروبا من امريكا
الشماليه للتواجد في قطر الى جانب الجاليه
المغربيه في قطر المقاهي المغربيه عدت
العده لكامله لتتحول الى منصات للفرجه حتى
البيوت المغربيه هنالك حاله السنفار
المونديال يغير من عادات الاسر وذلك
مطالبات من الطلبه من التلاميذ من
الموظفين بحق التغيب خلال التوقيت الاداري
والدراسي ليكون امام الشاشات مشجعين
لمنتخب المغرب في هذا العرس الكروي
العالمي نعم
طيب اذا تحدثنا عن مشاركه تونس مشاركه
المغرب كذلك الدوله العربيه كذلك للمشاركه
في مونديال قطر السعوديه المنتخب الاخضر
اذن حول مشاركته معنا الان همم زميلنا عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن
بك همم الاجواء والتحضيرات التي يدخل بها
المنتخب السعودي من قطر
نعم صهيب فعلا اجواء حماسيه جدا في
السعوديه
وترقب كبير لمباراه المنتخب السعودي ضد
منتخب التانجو الارجنتيني بعد يوم غدا
الثلاثاء الساعه 1:00 ظهرا طبعا الارجنتين
هذا المنتخب الذي السعوديين يتوجسون منه
خيفه بعض الشيء لكن هناك ايضا ثقه كبيره
بان اللاعبين الذين
المنتخب عربي يواجه الارجنتين في كاس
العالم يعني منذ بدايه المنافسات صحيح نعم
صحيح فربما يعني لاعبين تلقوا جرعه كبيره
عندما التقي بولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان قبل ايام والقى لهم كلمه
مهمه وقال لهم نريد منكم ان تستمتعوا
باللعب لننتظر منكم نتائج كبيره فقط نريد
ان تستمتع وتقدموا اداءا كبيرا كما
اعتدناه منكم هذه الكلمات اعطت اللاعبين
جرعه كبيره جدا ايضا حضور ولي العهد
السعودي اليوم الامير محمد بن سلمان في
افتتاح كاس العالم ايضا هذه دفعه معنويه
كبيره
للاعبين وايضا الجماهير السعوديه هنا في
مطار الرياض من حيث احدثكم تم تسير رحلات
تردديه يوميه لنقل المشجعين الى مطار
الدوحه
الحقيقه عبد الرحمن نعم
الجماهير السعوديه همم ستذهب لمشاهده
المباراه يوم الثلاثاء وتعود همم الى
السعوديه كيف يتم عمليه النقل عمليه
الاقامه كذلك هو علمنا كذلك على انه
السعوديه تستضيف كذلك اعداد لاباس بها
كذلك من المشجعين كذلك في السعوديه
بالضبط صهيب يعني مدينه الاحساء القريبه
من منفذ سلوى الحدود الوحيد لقطر ايضا
انتعشت سياحيا واقتصاديا بشكل كبير ونكل
كثير من السياح قرروا زياره هذه المدينه
والاستمتاع في معالمها التراثيه
والتاريخيه ايضا اكثر من 2300 رحله تردديه
ستنقل المشجعين طوال همم مباريات كاس
العالم من خمس مطارات في السعوديه مطار
الرياض وجده والدمام وايضا مطار المدينه
المنوره والقصيم هذه هي المطارات ستقبل
العديد من المشجعين ايضا السعوديه فتحت
ابوابها اي مشجع يحمل بطاقه هيا ااه
الخاصه بكاس العالم يستطيع الدخول الى
السعوديه بدون تاشيره ومجانا لمده 60 يوما
واكثر من دخول يعني مالتي انت السعوديه
هذه ايضا ستشجع الكثير من المشجعين في كاس
العالم في قطر الذهاب الى السعوديه الى
الاستمتاع في المواسم والفعاليات الموجوده
في اا سواء موسم رياض او حتى العلا او
ايضا المدن الاخرى في السعوديه من المتوقع
عن ان توفر هذه الرحلات 2,300 رحله صهيب
تقريبا سعه مقعديه
636,000 مقعد للمشجعين اعداد كبيره
استعدادات كبيره ستقوم بها المطارات في
السعوديه
للترحاب ايضا منصه حاضرين هذه المنصه التي
يقوم بالعمل بها اكثر من جهه حكوميه تقدم
الدعم والارشادات للمشجعين على مدار
الساعه الى جانب ايضا رقم 9 1 1 مركزليات
الامنيه الموحده
المنتخب السعودي ولكل المنتخبات العربيه
صحيح انا همم ذكرتها على اني اشجع
الارجنتين ولكن في هذه المباراه الوحيده
التي لن اشجع الارجنتين ساكون مع السعوديه
اذا شكرا جزيلا لكم شبكه مراثيه العربيه
اذن من الرياض عبد الرحمن العصيمي من
الرباط عدل الزبير ومن تون وليد عبد الله
[موسيقى]
ومع كل انطلاقه يتجدد النقاش حول من افضل
ليونيل ميسي ام كريستيانو رونالدو مع
استعداد النجمين لخامس مشاركه لهما فامسي
يخوض المونديال الخامس لهم مع الارجنتين
سعيا لرفع الكاس للمره الاولى في مسيرته
والثالثه في تاريخ المنتخب اما كريستيانو
سيطمح في قياده منتخب البرتغال للتتويج
بكاس العالم للمره الاولى في تاريخه فعلى
مداري اربع مشاركات لكريستيانو رونالدو في
كاس العالم خضر رونالدو سبعه عشره مباراه
واحرز سبعه اهداف وفي قطر يسعى لتحقيق
انجازا لم يشهده المونديال من قبل وهو
احراز الاهداف في خمس نسخ مختلفه من
البطوله اما ليونيل ميسي فيس عالي يتخط
الاسطوره الارجنتيني دييغو مارادونا الذي
خاض 21 مباراه تانجو في 40 نسخه من كاس
العالم في حين انا ميسي شارك في 9 10
مباراه احلىلها سته
دعونا الان مشاهدينا نتعرف على ابرز
الغائبين عن المونديال قطر في هذا العام
بسبب الاصابات البدايه طبعا مع المهاجم
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما الذي انضم الى قائمه
الغائبين عن مونديال قطر اذ اعلن الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم لاستبعاد المهاجم
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما من تشكيله منتخب
بلاده بعد تعرضه لاصابه اثناء التدريبات
الى جانبه بنزيما سيغيب لاعبه خطر
بوجبا ونقولوا كانفي اما في تشكيله
انجلترا فسغيب رئيس جيمس لاصابه في الركبه
وفي منتخب البرتغال فسيغيب مهاجم ليفربول
فاس الشخصي انها اخبار سيئه الى فرنسا
لانه مجرد لاعب تلو الاخر ثم ينتهي الامر
باصابه كريم بنزيما اثناء التدريبات لدينا
بالفعل الكثير من اللاعبين المصابين
والغائبين في كاس العالم لذا فالامر معقد
لكني محبط بعض الشيء لانه كان من رائع
وجود بنزيما في الفريق فهو اللاعب المخضرم
لم يكن لدينا بالفعل فرصه كبيره للفوز
والان ليست لدينا اي فرصه للفوز
[موسيقى]
التالي ايران اعتقل القوه الامن الايرانيه
لاحد الممثله عندما
خلعت حجابها على الملا في فيديو دعما
لحركه الاحتجاج التي اندلعت في ايران اثر
وفاه الشابه امين خلال اعتقالها حسبما
افادت وسائل الاعلام الرسميه
قد اشارت في وقت سابقا الا انها استدعيت
من قبل القضاء ثم نشرت فيديو خلعت فيه
حجابها وكتبت قد تكون هذه الرساله الاخيره
واضافت من الان فصاعدا مهما حدث لي اعلم
انني كالعاده مع الشعب الايراني حتى اخر
نفس لي وكان القضاء الايراني
[موسيقى]
سوريا سوريا
الغنيه بموارد الطاقه
ولم تسلم مياه الخليج من التهديدات
الايرانيه ايضا اصبحت جزء منها في العونات
الاخيره والدليل استهداف ناقله النفط
قباله خليجي عمان تهديدات كانت كافيه
لمضيء واشنطن قضمن في تسيير اكثر من 100
سفينه مسيره في مياه المنطقه الاستراتيجيه
بحلول العام المقبل عبر قوه المخصصه
للانظمه غير الماهوله اذا اهم من هي او ما
هي هذه القوه المسؤوله عن هذه المهمه
القوه 59 التي ستتولى نشر اكثر من 100
سفينه مسيره هي اول قوه من نوعها تابعه
للبحريه الامريكيه تدمج الانظمه غير
الماهوله والذكاء الاصطناعي مع العمليات
البحريه الخامس وهو الذي يغطي ما يقرب من
مليونين و500,000 ميل مربع تشمل الخليج
العربي وخليج عمان البحر الاحمر واجزاء من
المحيط الهندي
[موسيقى]
فيلم مقابل القلم المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني ان القرار
الاخير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
بشان البرنامج النووي لبلاده له اهداف
سياسيه من اجل زياده الضغط على طهران
واضاف كنعاني ان ايران لن تستسلم للضغوط
وستواصلوا برنامجها النوويه السلمي وفقا
لاحتياجات البلادي على حد وصفه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اوكرانيا تنفي
اعدام اسرار رؤوس وتقول ان موسكو
مقاطع الفيديو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد سلسله من الغارات الجويه
في شانها الجيش التركي
اخرها قبل اقل من ساعه استهدفت الريف
الغربيه للمدينه الغاره استهدفت مواقع
لقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه الكرديه في عين
العرب وعين عيساوه رفعت شمالي سوريا القصف
التركيه اصفر او وقوع عدد كبير من القتل
والجرحى بينهما عدد من المدنيين فيما وصفت
الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه بسوريا القصفه
التركيه بالعدوان غير المبرر مضيفه
التفجير اسطنبول ما هو الا ذريعه لتبرير
هجوم انقره على شمالي وشرق سوريا
ههه نتابع اذا مباشره من اربيل مع مراسلنا
احمد الحمداني احمد اخر التطورات
صهيب كان اليوم شهيده قصف عنيف جدا في
المناطق
الشمال الشرقي من اربيل والتحديدا جبل
قنديل ومناطق برادوس وايضا اا قضاء موت
وهذه المناطق هي قريبه من ايران وايضا
قريبه من الحدود العراقيه التركيه طبعا
بحسب المصادر فان اكثر من 70 همم ضربه
جويه همم تركيا همم استهدفت هذه الاماكن
التي هي تضم مسلح حزب العمال الكردستاني
المعارض دي انقره هناك انباء عن قتلى
وجرحى بين صفوف حزب العمال كردستايل لكن
لم لم تعرف الحصيله للاوليه ولا حتى
النهائيه في مقابل احمد كان هناك يعني قصف
على مواقع تركيه كذلك
قصف على مواقع تركيه
بالفعل رداد فعل كانت في بعض الاماكن
طبعا
المواقع التركيه هي هي فوق قمم جبال
عراقيه في بمحافظه دهوم محافظه دهوك تشهد
اكثر من 30 الى 40 معسكر ونقطه
ومرصد للقوات التركيه فوق الجبال فوق
القمم الجبليه وتستخدم همم يستخدم همم
الجيش التركي الطائرات في التنقل ما بين
القمم الجبال وتستهدف بين الفين والاخرى
صويب بصواريخ مضاده همم من قبل مسلحين حزب
العمال كردستاني الذين يحاولون ان يباغته
المعسكرات فوق قمم الجبال بصواريخ همم
قصيره المدى ولكنها تصل الى اهدافها في
قبم الجبال محاول ان يوقعوا خسائر بين
صفوف القوى القوات الجيش او الجيش الجنود
الجيش التركي احمد الحمداني من شكرا جزيلا
لك
دوري وصفا وزير الدفاعي التركيه خلصي اكار
الغارات الجويه بانها كانت الضروريه ان
التخطيط لها كان دقيقه وحساسه
في هذا السياق العمليه التي نفذت ضد اهداف
ارهابيه في شمال العراق وشمال سوريا منذ
منتصف ليل هذا المساء تم التخطيط لها
بحساسيه
ولحسن الحظ كما تنفيذها بنجاح
معنا من اسطنبول الاستاذ العلاقات الدوليه
دكتور سمير صالحه دكتور سمير هل تعتقد ان
تركيا ستتوقف عند هذا الحد في الرد على
تفجير اسطنبول ام نحن امام عمليه عسكريه
قد تكون اوسع واشمل في شمال سوريا
مساء الخير للجميع اولا طبعا يعني
القيادات السياسيه والعسكريه التركيه في
الساعات الاخيره
بيان وزاره الدفاع التركي تصريحات خلوصي
عكار تغريداته برايي تترك الباب مفتوحه
الابواب مشرعه ما اكثر من احتمال انا قبل
قليل
الليله رصدت الكثير من وسائل الاعلام
التركيه غالبيه التحليلات لخبراء ومحللين
اتراك عسكريين وسياسيين من الطراز الاول
يتحدثون عن عمليه بريئه ايضا في هذه
المرحله يعني عمليه جديده استكماليه همم
اذا كانت هذه المعلومات صحيحه في يبدو انه
نعم همم
العمليه لم تتوقف فقط فقط
لكن انا وانت علينا ايضا ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار انه هذا التحرك العسكري الجديد
مرتبط ليس فقط بموضوع استهداف تقسيم هذا
العمل الارهابي مرتبط ايضا طريقه تردد
الفعل التركيه والتحضير لهذه الطريقه هذا
التنسيق الاقليمي والدول الواسعه التي
الهدف ابعد الهدف هو المنطقه العازله ربما
في شمال سوريا
مطروح منذ فتره زمنيه طويله لكن الان هل
يعني يتم تحريك او تفعيل هذا المخططات
بهذا الشكل لا اعرف تماما لكن اعرف انه
انقره احتمال النقد لا تتوقف عند مساله
الغارات خصوصا اذا ما جاء اي رد او
استفزاز للقوات همم المتواجده في شمال شرق
سوريا اقصد مجموعات قصائد ومسد وغيرها همم
مجموعات حزب العمال الارهابي يعني اي
تصعيد او محاوله تصعيد او تحرش همم امني
او عسكري برايي عندها انا وانت اكثر من
سيناريو جديد مرتبط بهذا ال- الملف
الدكتور سمير صالح العلاقات الدوليه من
اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا لك
ده نفى دي مترو لوبنتس المكلف بالحقوق
الانسانيه الاوكرانيه حول اعدامها اسرع
حرب روس بحسب ما ظهر في احد مقاطع الفيديو
قال انه لحادثه وقعت في الثانيه عشر من
نوفمبر في قريه
بلوجاستق موضحا ان المقطع اجتزاته روسيا
ونشرته لتقول انه دليل على عمليات اعدام
جنود الروس سلموا انفسهم لكنه في الحقيقه
فان الروس تظاهره بالاستلام ثم فتحوا
النار على الاوكرانيين وبالتالي لا يمكن
اعتبار ما قام به الا دفاعا عن النفس عن
النفس اما روسيا تستغل قانون الحمايه
الدولي لتقتل المزيد على حد وصفحه
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه مجموعه السبعه
تدين واطلاقه كوريا الشماليه صاروخان
بالسيارات تعتبره تهديدا خطيره
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد لا تزال وتداعيات
القرار او القرارات الاخيره التي اتخذها
مالك تويتر الجديد الملياردير الامريكيه
لهم ماسك مستمره الا انها جاءت هذه المره
على شكل تحذير متزامن مع انطلاق الحدث
الكروي اضخم في قطع فقد اكد مطلعون من
الشركه ان العصفور الازرق امام احتمال
مواجهه انهيار كبير خلال كاس العالم مضحين
ان عملاقه وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي غير
مجهز للتعامل مع الطفرات المروريه خصوصا
بعد الاجراءات الاخيره التي فرضها الى
الماسك هذا بعد تغييره سريعه وجذريه على
منصه العصفور الازرق بعد سلسله تغريده
لملكها الى الماسك يوضح فيها سياسات جديده
على حريه التعبير هذا هو اطلق مستخدم
تويتر
ارقد بسلام خوفا من ان تكون اخر مره
يستخدمون فيها المنصه
[موسيقى]
صحيفه الجاردن البريطانيه كشفت في تقرير
لها ان تويتر قد يواجه حدوث انقطاع كبير
يؤدي الى تعطيل الموقع اثناء منافسات كاس
العالم وما اكده موظف سابق غادر مؤخرا
الشركه مشددا ان فريق المنصه على درايه
باعطال راقبوها مؤخرا بحثا عن مشكلات مثل
ضغط الحركه على الموقع وانقطاع الاتصال
بمركز البيع وتابع ان كاس العالم سيكون
صعبا على المنصه وسطى الافتقار الى
الاستعدادات ونقص الموظفين تقرير الصحيفه
نقلا عن الموظف همم قدرت احتماليه حدوث
اخطاء مثل الاستجابه بطيئه او غير صحيحه
او خدمه غير مكتمله بنسبه 90%
من امام المقر الرئيسي لشركه تويوتا في
سان فرانسيسكو انا من هناك مراسل العربيه
حسين الطاود اهلا بك معنا بدايه الى اين
وصلت ازمه موظفي تويتر المستقيم
تحيه لك صهيب في الواقع لا نبالغ قلنا
الان بان تويتر بقياده لهم ماسك بدخلها
بامتحان صعب بالتجمع مع بدايه كاس العالم
وتحذير من انه قد يتعرض للانقطاع لهم ماسك
من دون نحو خمسه ساعات غرد مطالبا بمتابعه
التويتر من اجل تغطيه افضل لكاس العالم في
تغريده تحمله وفي مضمونها تحديا لهؤلاء
الخبراء التقنيين الذين
يرجحوا ان ينهار الموقع بالنسبه
للموظفين طبعا همم عددهم الان كما ذكرت
نيويورك تايمز اكثر من 1,000 و200 موظف تم
استقاله مؤخرا بين يومين الاخ همم الاخرين
والان هناك احتمال ان يقيل له ماسك يوم
الاثنين غدا عددا من الموظفين لكن هذه
المره سيكون من موظفين همم المبيعات
والترويج او همم
تسويق الاعلامي في شركه تويتر همم
عايز تنزاف على ما يبدو مستمر رغم ان هناك
من يتحدث عن تضارب في القرارات التي
تاخدها مصر فمثلا يوم الجمعه كانت طالب
باجتماع بعقد اجتماع مع مجموعه من
الموظفين الذين يوجدون البرمجه ما راه
البعض بانه مؤشر على ازمه تويتر من خلال
وجود تقنيين يعملون على تفادي اي اعطال
كما تفضلتها فيها الخبر همم انت عند مقر
الشركه همم حسين هل تمكنت من رصد اي حركه
غريبه يعني نقول للموظفين علما انه ماسك
على ما اعتقد هو منع الموظفين من الوصول
الى المكتب خاصه المستقلين منهم
صهيب البارحه شاهدنا عدد من الاشخاص يدخل
الى مقر ااا مقر تويتر حاولنا
نلحقهم ونسالهم ان كانوا موظفين يريدون ان
يدخل الى المقر ولكن ساعتها رجال الامن
اتوا الينا وطالبون بالنبقه بعيدين عن
المبلغ في الشارع لان اعتبر المكان الذي
دخلنا اليه
ممتلكات خاصه طبعا اليوم يوم احد اساسا
اليوم عطله والقرار والقرار له الماس بان
يبقى المكان مغلق حتى يوم الاثنين نتوقع
غدا الاثنين ان يكون هناك اقبال نسيمه من
الموظفين الذين بقوا مع الى الناس ونتوقع
ولكن ليس لدينا معلومات مؤكده نتوقع بعد
الموظفين الذين استقاله ربما لياخذ
اغراضهم اليوم كان لافته هنا ان انا وجدنا
بعض وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه تغطي من امام
المطار في اليومين الماضيه لم نشاهد
الكثير من الوسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
اليوم شاهدنا نتوقع غدا ايضا ان يكون هناك
وسائل الاعلام لتغطي على الحدث تغطي بعوده
الموظفين الى مقر شركه وايضا احتمال ان
ياتي الموظفون الذين استقالوا لياخذوا
اغراضهم الشخصيه من هناك نعم همم كذلك هل
همم علمت اذا كان الى الماسك لديه خطه
لانه همم مع همم تصريح نصف الموظفين
الموظفين الذين استقالوا والان حديث على
ان ربما سيقيل المزيد من الموظفين كذلك هل
لديه خطه لاستقدام موظفين اخرين همم اما
ماذا سيفعل حسين
في اليومين الماضيين سمعنا بان ادم ماسك
طلبه من عدد من المهندسين في شركات اخرى
مثل الشركات تسلم بان ياتوا الى مقر همم
تويتر هنا في سان فرانسيسكو يساعده همم
على صيانه الموقع وايضا طلب بعدد من
المهندسين اماكن مختلفه الى مقر همم تويتر
ما يدل الكثير من المراقبين على انه
يستعين بالمهندسين الذين يعملون لديه في
شركات اخرى ولكن طبعا الايام القادمه صهيب
هي من ستحدد من اذا كان قالوا مصر سينجح
في هذا الامتحانات الذي دخله وان كان
سيبقى تويتر بدون ان تحدث له اي مشاكل
انقطاع في الانترنت وان يبقى مستمرا بين
سيابيه كما عهدنا سابقا من امام المقر
الرئيسي لشركه تويتر شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
اداءنا بيان وزراء خارجيه في مجموعه الدول
السبع اطلاقه كوريا الشماليه صاروخان
عابرا للقارات بالعمل الخطير وغير
القانوني والمتهور حيث يتفقد كل من
الولايات المتحده واليابان وكندا والمانيا
وبريطانيا وفرنسا وايطاليا على جمع
اصواتهم لمطالبه مجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده بضروره اتخاذ التدابير حازمه من
قبل المجتمع الدولي للرد على افعال كوريا
الشماليهين والدوليين معربين عن خلقهم
ازاءها اسلحه نوويه
[موسيقى]
حضر فريق رصدي ثوران البراكين في جزيرتي
كامشوكه شرق روسيا من ان بوركانا شيبلوتش
في شبه الجزيره اصبح نشطا للغايه مما يهدد
انفجار بركانيه
البركانيه مستمر ويرافقه قبه وانفجارات
بالاضافه الى انهيارات جليديه
عسى انتهت اليكم تكيرا بابرز اخبارها
بشعار التسامح والتعايش كاس العالم قطر
2022 ينطلق معلن بدء التظاهره الكرويه
الاكبر في العالم
في ايران احكام عرفيه بالاعدام سماء ومها
باد ملبده بالمسيرات وفنانه ايرانيه تحدث
النظام بالحجاب فاعتقلات
[موسيقى]
ودانه الشيطان
الرجيم
[موسيقى]
اسطنبول والعربيه تصل الى خط التماس
وتتابع من هناك
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى العربيه على مواقع التواصل الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]